Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
"Politiques, à table !" sur LCP,
où on parle cuisine,
alimentation, agriculture,
mais aussi politique
et nous recevons cette semaine
un invité exceptionnel, Jean-Pierre
Darroussin, bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être là et avec moi pour
présenter, Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour, Jean-Pierre Darroussin.
-Vous êtes
acteur et réalisateur,
vous êtes pour nous tous
un visage très connu
du cinéma français
depuis les années 80,
que l'on associe à Robert
Guédiguian, dont vous êtes
un acteur fétiche.
Votre filmographie est immense,
retenons une liste non
exhaustive de mes films préférés,
"Mes meilleurs
copains",
"Cuisine et dépendances",
"Un air de famille", qui vous vaut
le prix du meilleur acteur
dans un 2nd rôle, "Marius
et Jeannette, "Le coeur des hommes",
ou encore "Le bureau des légendes",
où vous campez le personnage
d'Henri Duflot, Socrate,
aux cravates franchement moches,
on peut le dire.
On peut vous voir actuellement
dans "Le théorème de Marguerite"
d'Anna Novion,
et dans "Et la fête continue",
toujours Robert Guédiguian,
et au théâtre
dans "Le principe d'incertitude"
mis en scène
par Louis-Do de Lencquesaing.
Par votre carrière, vous incarnez
le cinéma hexagonal
et c'est donc sans surprise
que vous nous avez demandé
une valeur sûre.
-Oui, pardi !
Une blanquette de veau. En dessert,
un peu plus exotique,
une pavlova aux mangues.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
connaissez-vous
la vraie,
l'authentique bouillabaisse ?
Clément Perrouault
l'a dégustée
au port des Goudes à Marseille.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
la précarité alimentaire augmente,
les Restos du coeur sont débordés,
obligés de refuser du monde.
Reportage à suivre.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Jean-Pierre Darroussin,
pour deviner votre plat,
j'ai d'abord décortiqué
votre filmographie,
où il y a à boire
et à manger. J'ai compris que
vous feriez l'impasse sur la viande
de porc, car "De bon matin",
visiblement, le cri
du cochon vous effraie.
Surtout lorsqu'il résonne
dans "Cuisine et dépendances".
J'ai émis l'hypothèse du "Poulpe"
que j'ai vite abandonnée,
car même préparé
dans "Le grand restaurant",
dans "L'eau froide",
avec "Le cactus",
ça reste
difficilement comestible.
Vous allez me dire,
c'est "Le goût des autres",
en tous les cas, ce n'est pas
le mien, j'ai vaguement imaginé
un clin d'oeil avec un gras double,
vous qui avez dirigé
des agents doubles
dans "Le bureau des légendes",
ayant fait chou blanc
dans la famille du cinéma,
je me suis rabattu
sur la famille tout court
et j'ai trouvé un moment
de vérité, une séquence
émotion, sur France Culture,
un hommage à votre maman
et à sa blanquette de veau
de compét avec des pommes de terre
et de la crème. On vous a donc
préparé une blanquette. Sera-t-elle
à la hauteur ? Vous nous le direz.
-On a le droit de manger ?
-Bien sûr !
On a l'obligation de manger.
-On va même la goûter ensemble
si vous voulez bien.
-Avec grand plaisir.
Oui, c'est vrai
que c'est un hommage à ma maman.
C'était le...
...le plat
que tout le monde lui réclamait.
Voilà.
Elle le réussissait.
Et quand on mangeait
une blanquette de veau à la maison,
il y avait le silence à table.
-Silence absolu.
-Absolu.
Et c'était remarquable.
Au bout d'un moment,
on se rendait compte que personne
ne parlait,
contrairement à d'habitude.
-On ne va pas vous faire l'offense
de vous demander si elle est
aussi bonne que celle de votre
maman, mais vous rappelle-t-elle
quelques souvenirs d'enfance ?
-Elle est pas mal du tout.
-Oui ! Votre maman mettait
des pommes de terre.
-Oui.
-Vous parlez de ces pommes de terre
comme si c'était des bijoux.
J'ai regardé, il y a
pas souvent des pommes de terre.
-C'est souvent du riz.
-Oui, souvent.
Ca arrivait qu'elle le fasse
avec du riz aussi,
mais c'est vrai que j'aimais bien
avec des pommes de terre vapeur.
-Avec la sauce par-dessus.
Un peu fondante.
-Voilà.
J'ai toujours bien aimé.
Un de mes repas préférés
à la maison,
c'était tout simplement
des pommes de terre
cuites à l'eau avec du beurre.
-Simple.
-Au beurre, au sel et voilà.
J'adorais quand on me faisait ça,
j'adorais ça.
-Cette blanquette de veau,
c'était réservé
pour, je sais pas,
les repas du dimanche,
les fêtes de famille
ou elle en faisait régulièrement ?
-Le repas du dimanche.
-Ah oui, donc c'était
un repas un peu exceptionnel
avec toute la famille réunie.
-Alors, la famille, elle était quand
même assez restreinte, on était
quatre, mon père, ma mère,
ma soeur et moi.
C'est une famille
tout à fait restreinte,
il y avait pas beaucoup de place,
ça faisait quand même rempli.
Non, mais, en fait, on mangeait
pas tant de viande que ça.
J'ai plutôt eu la chance
de naître à une époque
où, je dirais que les 15 premières
années de ma vie,
quasiment,
entre mes vacances à la campagne
et manger chez moi...
Moi, je suis issu d'un milieu
ouvrier paysan, donc on était
dans une grande banlieue, mais
dans une petite bicoque de banlieue,
mais il y avait un jardin
avec un potager.
Comme beaucoup de gens à l'époque,
moi, j'ai passé
toute mon enfance à manger
des produits...
-Que vous récoltiez vous-mêmes.
-Voilà. Qui étaient là,
qui poussaient là. On mangeait
des poireaux, des endives,
des carottes, il y avait des...
-Des courges peut-être ?
-Des courges.
-C'était votre papa,
votre maman, tout le monde ?
-Des voisins aussi.
-Une sorte de jardin partagé.
-Une sorte de jardin partagé, oui.
-Et ça faisait vivre
plusieurs familles ?
-Oui, on était deux familles.
Sur ce...
Sur ce petit jardin,
oui. Mais après, évidemment,
quand j'allais dans la famille
en vacances, puisqu'on m'envoyait
en vacances à la campagne,
dans le Berry,
quand j'étais gamin, tout le temps,
régulièrement,
que ça soit à Noël, à Pâques,
pendant les grandes vacances
qui à l'époque
duraient presque trois mois,
ça durait longtemps.
Non, c'est pas long.
En fait, c'est assez logique.
Dans les...
Le mois de septembre, c'est un mois
dans les campagnes où on a besoin
de main-d'oeuvre,
on moissonne,
les récoltes, tout ça.
Donc fallait pas les envoyer
à l'école, les gamins.
-Oui, oui.
-Vous, vous avez participé
par exemple ?
-Bien sûr,
jusqu'à l'âge
de 18 ans, j'ai fait la batteuse,
j'attendais impatiemment
d'avoir 14 ans pour pouvoir
conduire le tracteur.
Donc, c'est...
Et là, alors là, le potager était
beaucoup plus grand, mais oui,
on mangeait que des produits,
des choses qui sortaient. Et
ça a un goût, ça a une saveur.
-Sauf les pommes de terre,
vous racontez
qu'on allait les chercher ailleurs,
il me semble.
-Alors, oui, ça,
c'était à Courbevoie,
dans la banlieue
où j'étais avec mes parents.
Oui. Mes parents avaient
avec les voisins...
Les pommes de terre,
il faut un peu de terrain.
-Oui.
-On n'en avait pas tant que ça.
Mes parents avaient un plan
pour aller dans la vallée
de Chevreuse, dans une grande ferme,
où on allait se faire livrer,
acheter des sacs de 50 kilos
de pommes de terre.
Et donc, vous reveniez
avec des sacs de 50 kilos
de pommes de terre.
-J'ai retenu que vous disiez,
ma maman, c'était la vedette
quand elle faisait...
c'était son heure de gloire.
-Oui, oui, c'est vrai.
Je dois reconnaître
que mon père était un peu
celui qui avait
la parole à la maison.
On était...
C'est une représentation familiale
un peu à l'ancienne.
-Patriarcale.
Et ma mère était plutôt discrète,
mais...
mais sa satisfaction,
son sourire et sa joie
quand elle nous voyait
manger était tout à fait...
Vous avez un petit truc, là.
-Ah !
-Vous tenez de votre maman
ou de votre papa ?
-Pardon ?
-Vous tenez
de votre maman ?
-Je crois que les gens qui ont connu
mon père, quand ils me voient,
ils savent bien d'où je viens.
Rires
-Vous nous disiez
que vous cultiviez ces légumes.
Est-ce que vous,
on vous retrouvait
derrière les fourneaux, parfois ?
Vous aimez cuisiner ?
-Oui, oui, moi, je...
Oui, oui, tout de suite,
je me suis intéressé et puis,
quand j'ai commencé à habiter
en dehors de mes parents,
quand j'ai pris mon émancipation,
j'ai habité avec des camarades.
On était en communauté,
on avait loué un pavillon, tout ça,
et on s'intéressait beaucoup à la...
...à la cuisine et aux magasins
bio. On achetait que des légumes,
on achetait des graines,
on achetait tout un tas de produits.
-Vous étiez très avant-gardistes,
à l'époque ?
-On n'était pas
du tout avant-gardistes,
mes parents, en 1946,
à la fin de la guerre,
ils étaient adhérents
à la Vie claire, qui est un circuit
qui s'est monté à cette époque-là.
L'écologie et le fait d'essayer
de se nourrir bien, les gens, c'est
pas nouveau,
les gens avaient déjà compris
qu'on allait
dans un monde industriel
et qu'il fallait faire gaffe.
-Ce goût
des bons légumes, de l'authentique
légume que vous aviez enfant,
vous le retrouvez aujourd'hui ?
Allez-vous
justement dans des enseignes
spécialisées bio
pour retrouver ce goût
et existe-t-il encore ?
-Alors...
J'ai la chance
d'avoir une maison secondaire
dans le sud de la France
et autour de chez moi, il y a,
je suis entouré par un maraîcher.
Et ce maraîcher, donc, vraiment,
je mange de ses produits,
lui est pas bio du tout.
-Ah.
-Non.
-Vous avez essayé de le convaincre ?
-Il s'y met vaguement. Bon, non,
lui, le convaincre, c'est difficile,
mais il... mais il fait
des trucs formidables,
mais
je vois bien,
même quand c'est pas bio,
la qualité d'un légume
est formidable
quand vous mangez quelque chose
qui a été cueilli le matin.
-C'est frais.
-Voilà.
Transporter des légumes, transporter
des fruits, le transport altère
totalement la qualité gustative.
-Ca les abîme
ou il faut
les transporter pas mûrs.
-Il faut des quantités.
-Vous êtes
plus local que bio.
Vous préférez aller
à côté de chez vous acheter un
produit même s'il a des pesticides ?
-Bah, j'évite quand même. J'essaie
de... Oui, non, des pesticides,
c'est évidemment...
Evidemment que c'est très nocif
pour l'organisme, ça détruit
beaucoup de choses à l'intérieur,
notre façon de s'adapter,
ça finit par détruire
des choses très importantes
comme notre système immunitaire.
Donc il faut évidemment
y faire attention.
Mais au niveau gustatif,
vraiment, la fraîcheur
et manger quelque chose de local,
ça, évidemment, c'est imbattable.
C'est imbattable.
-On va revenir
sur cette blanquette. Jean-Pierre,
vous allez
nous dire 3 secrets
de chefs pour cuisiner
la blanquette.
-Alors, je ne sais pas quel était
le secret de la maman
de Jean-Pierre Darroussin,
mais les chefs ont des secrets
pour finir la recette au moment
où on doit faire la petite crème
qui finit la blanquette.
Pour Cyril Lignac,
pas de bonne blanquette
sans ce roux,
préparé avec du beurre,
de la farine et le bouillon parfumé
de la viande, auquel il ajoute
de la crème fraîche.
Mais pour lui,
jamais d'oeuf, c'est un sacrilège.
En revanche, l'oeuf est
le secret de Jean-François Piège qui
le fouette dans le restant de crème
avant de verser une louche
de sauce très chaude,
pour détendre la crème,
et de verser cette composition
sur la blanquette.
Enfin, Philippe Etchebest,
pas d'oeuf, mais de la crème.
Cette crème, il va fouetter
pour la rendre aérienne,
légère, onctueuse.
Il va y ajouter un peu de citron
pour la prendre, pour la tendre,
et il l'ajoute à sa blanquette.
Voilà 3 secrets de chefs
pour réussir une blanquette.
-J'ai jamais vu ma mère
mettre un oeuf dans une blanquette.
-Ah, jamais d'oeuf.
-Je ne crois pas.
-Comme Lignac.
-Par contre,
le citron, je pense que oui.
-Qui relaie,
qui donne une pointe d'acidité.
Elle vous a transmis
sa recette ?
Vous, vous la faites, la blanquette
à la maison ?
-Non.
Non, c'était sa recette
et je pense que...
Elle transmettait pas,
elle avait ses prérogatives.
-Vous en mangez
toujours volontiers
ou ça fait partie d'une madeleine
qui reste un souvenir ?
-Ca fait partie d'une madeleine
qui reste un souvenir,
auquel je... Voilà. Donc,
ça m'arrive si... Ca m'arrive
d'en manger dans les restaurants,
mais c'est pas un plat
qu'on prépare à la maison.
-On n'a pas compris
si vous étiez un artiste
derrière les fourneaux.
Vous l'êtes derrière
l'écran et la caméra.
Vous faites ça par devoir,
par obligation ?
-Non,
j'aime être dans la recherche
des saveurs, de faire des mélanges,
tout ça, enfin,
j'aime bien tester des choses.
J'aime élaborer des plats.
Mais il se trouve
que je... je vis en couple,
avec une femme qui fait
très, très bien la cuisine aussi,
donc on se partage, on est
tous les deux aux fourneaux.
-Ensemble ?
-Oui, ensemble.
-C'est pas
toujours simple d'être...
-Non, ça va, je fais le commis.
-Ah ! Chacun a son rôle.
-Voilà, je fais
le commis volontiers.
-Vous avez accepté d'être second,
mais vous ne jouez
que des premiers rôles.
-Pas forcément,
mais je trouve ça très intéressant
aussi d'être second.
Ca ne m'a jamais...
Je ne me suis jamais senti minoré
parce que j'étais second.
Euh... Non, c'est...
Non, oui, j'ai accepté ça,
mais ça m'arrive aussi
que ce soit moi qui dirige.
Si c'est moi qui ai l'initiative.
Mais elle l'a plus souvent
que moi. Voilà.
-Vous nous parliez d'une maison
dans le sud, c'est plutôt
la cuisine méditerranéenne ?
Quels plats cuisinez-vous
régulièrement ?
-Oui, alors c'est vrai que les gens
sont contents de venir, par exemple,
là, c'est moi qui le fais, la soupe
au pistou. La soupe au pistou,
c'est moi qui la fais.
-C'est bon.
-Typique de la cuisine du sud.
-Au mortier, le pistou ?
-Oui, oui.
Je suis un spécialiste du mortier.
Pour les aïolis.
Non, mais c'est vrai,
je suis spécialiste du travail,
il faut un bon mortier.
Oui, oui.
-Alors, l'aïoli,
comment vous le faites ?
On écrase beaucoup d'ail
et on le monte à l'huile ?
-Oui,
absolument.
Oui, oui, c'est tout simple,
c'est une mayonnaise
où on remplace...
-Il faut un bon coup de patte.
-A la place de la moutarde,
vous faites votre pâte d'ail
et puis, vous montez ça.
Mais une mayonnaise,
je suis aussi spécialiste.
On me demande aussi
toujours de la faire.
C'est moi qui la fais.
-Vous avez un plat préféré
dont vous n'avez pas parlé,
mais on a trouvé,
c'est la tomate farcie.
-Oui.
Je sais, justement...
Mais c'est aussi lié à ma mère.
Elle les faisait très, très bien,
elles étaient délicieuses,
ses tomates farcies.
Et je sais que,
quand elle voulait me faire plaisir,
j'avais droit à des tomates farcies.
Il y avait deux trucs,
les côtelettes
de porc et les tomates
farcies, ça, c'était pour moi.
Ca m'était
destiné.
-C'était pour vous.
Ce sont des souvenirs d'enfance.
Et pour accompagner
cette blanquette,
vous nous avez demandé
un verre de vin de Bandol.
Donc nous avons choisi
ce rosé de Provence.
C'est une AOC Bandol
contrôlée, millésime 2022.
Le cépage
qu'on retrouve là-bas,
c'est la "mourvrède",
le "mourvrède".
-Le mourvèdre.
-C'est difficile à dire.
Et puis, c'est un rosé,
donc il y a beaucoup de fraîcheur,
il y a beaucoup de fruité,
des notes d'agrumes.
Vous nous aviez
demandé un Bandol rouge
ou sinon rosé. J'étais un peu
étonnée par la couleur.
Le rosé, c'est plutôt l'été,
mais on en trouve maintenant
toute l'année.
-Oui, je suis tout à fait
pour promouvoir
et réhabiliter le rosé,
qui est un vin qui va vraiment,
sur un repas, ça va
avec tout, depuis l'entrée
jusqu'au dessert,
ça va très bien.
Alors, évidemment,
il faut qu'il soit
de très bonne qualité.
On a des rosés qu'on a
justement, on a fait
un peu pisser la vigne
pour pouvoir
faire de la consommation rapide
et en quantité l'été, pour faire
boire du rosé, tout ça,
mais il y a des gens
qui travaillent bien
et qui font des rosés
vraiment délicieux.
Et le rosé peut être
un vin merveilleux.
Evidemment, j'aime beaucoup
les rouges aussi
et le blanc,
mais il se trouve qu'en Bandol,
les blancs sont merveilleux,
les rouges sont merveilleux
et les rosés aussi.
-Effectivement.
-Et Bandol est une région
que vous aimez
particulièrement, pour y passer
quelques vacances ?
-Parce que, justement,
cette maison secondaire
dont je parlais tout à l'heure,
elle est dans les vignes,
entourée d'un maraîcher,
mais les vignes sont là aussi,
pas très loin,
du côté des vignes de Bandol.
-Brigitte, peut-être,
ce qui galvaude le rosé,
c'est que les Français le boivent
quand il fait chaud.
Sous la fraîcheur,
on cache n'importe quel vin.
C'est peut-être
une bonne idée
de le boire l'hiver.
Pour réhabiliter le rosé.
-Il est pas glacé, là.
-Non, mais on peut trouver
aujourd'hui de très bons rosés.
Même s'il est frais,
un mauvais rosé, on peut trouver
qu'il est mauvais.
Mais ça, c'est un goût personnel.
-Buvons du rosé,
enfin, avec modération,
l'hiver, pourquoi pas.
-Modérément.
-J'ai pas de problème
pour boire, quand il est bon,
si c'est un bon rosé,
c'est bon, voilà.
-On va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollable. C'est le Quiz.
-Jean-Pierre Darroussin, on l'a vu,
les tomates farcies
sont un de vos plats préférés.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
concernant cette fameuse tomate
sont vraies
ou fausses. La tomate est
un légume-fruit
originaire du Mexique.
Vrai ou faux ?
-C'est vrai.
-Du mot tomati en langue aztèque.
Certains disent que c'est le Pérou,
mais le berceau de la tomate,
c'est le Mexique.
Ce sont
les sans-culottes marseillais
qui, juste après la Révolution,
en 1790,
font découvrir
la tomate aux Parisiens.
-C'est probable.
-Oui, parce qu'elle arrive
dans les soutes de Colomb
par l'Espagne et l'Italie,
donc à Marseille d'abord. En France,
on pense que c'est une plante
et un fruit de décoration
et pas un légume.
Les Marseillais vont faire goûter
la tomate aux Parisiens. En France,
la 1re recette de tomates farcies
à base de chair à saucisse
est publiée en 1803
par Grimod de La Reynière.
-En 1803, pourquoi pas,
puisque c'était les sans-culottes
qui l'ont amenée, on est cohérents.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
La logique est imparable.
C'est le chef drômois
que vous devez connaître, André Pic,
qui fait entrer la tomate farcie
dans la gastronomie française.
-Alors,
euh... je crois que oui.
-Alors, non, c'est Paul Bocuse
qui, en 1976, fait
une recette gastronomique,
la tomate farcie entre dans
le Panthéon de la cuisine française.
-3 bonnes réponses sur 4,
c'est pas mal. 2e quiz,
vous, l'acteur du film
"Le coeur des hommes",
sauriez-vous nous dire
quel coeur en cuisine est désigné
par un espèce de bulbe
qui unit les branches ?
Elle lit les 4 propositions.
...
Un bulbe qui unit
les branches.
-Bah, euh...
Alors, le premier,
vous avez dit, c'est ?
-Le coeur de laitue.
-Oui, c'est le coeur de laitue.
-Non, c'est pas le coeur de laitue,
c'est le coeur de céleri.
-Ah, le céleri, d'accord, le bulbe,
oui, bien sûr, le céleri,
c'est un bulbe.
J'avais oublié le mot bulbe.
-C'était le piège.
-Alors, c'est souvent
autour de la table,
Jean-Pierre Darroussin,
que se racontent les histoires,
que se nouent parfois des deals
politiques, que se fait l'histoire.
C'est La brève de comptoir.
Jean-Pierre Darroussin,
on vous a demandé de réfléchir
à une anecdote autour d'un repas,
pourquoi pas en politique, mais
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs
de repas avec des hommes
ou des femmes politiques ?
-Ca m'est arrivé quelquefois, oui,
mais justement,
si on retourne à Bandol,
je jouais "Art" au théâtre Antoine,
avec Charles Berling
et Alain Fromager,
une pièce de Yasmina Reza,
qu'on a jouée pas mal,
ça a fait un gros succès et...
Emmanuel Macron et sa femme Brigitte
sont venus voir le spectacle.
Et après le spectacle, dans le...
...dans le foyer
du théâtre, une table
a été rapidement dressée,
des bouteilles ont été sorties
et on a mangé ensemble
après le spectacle, comme ça,
et on parlait du spectacle.
Et la conversation est venue
justement sur Bandol, parce que...
Il disait, avec Brigitte,
on va souvent en vacances à Bandol,
tout ça, machin.
Et là, Emmanuel Macron me dit,
mais le vin de Bandol maintenant,
c'est mieux, mais avant,
c'était pas terrible.
Là, je lui ai dit, là...
-Attendez.
-Monsieur le Président,
vous êtes un peu jeunot
sur la question, parce que,
ça fait quand même
quelques années,
c'est une des régions
où les viticulteurs
sont en grande majorité
bio et en biodynamie
depuis très longtemps et ceux
qui ne l'étaient pas l'étaient
sans le savoir, comme M. Jourdain
faisait de la prose
sans le savoir. Moi, je connais
des viticulteurs de Bandol
qui en sont
à leur 64 ou 65e vinification
tellement ils y sont
depuis longtemps
et ils ont jamais mis un intrant,
jamais mis un pesticide,
quoi que ce soit
dans leurs vignes. Ils ont toujours
été très précautionneux.
-Il y a moins d'humidité aussi,
donc moins
de mildiou.
-Peut-être les conditions
sont bonnes, mais en tous les cas,
ils en profitent
et ils en font profiter
les autres aussi de ce travail.
Donc voilà mon anecdote
avec de la politique
autour d'un repas.
-Vous avez bâché
le président.
-Ah, je l'ai bâché.
-Depuis,
il boit du Bandol.
Je le disais,
vous êtes un des acteurs
fétiches de Robert Guédiguian,
il a dû vous emmener
manger une bouillabaisse
dans son fief. Quel est le secret
de cet emblème de la cuisine
marseillaise ?
C'est Le dessous des plats.
-Alors, évidemment,
impossible d'évoquer Marseille
sans évoquer la bouillabaisse,
un totem de la cuisine phocéenne,
souvent
copié, parfois massacré,
à quoi ressemble l'authentique
bouillabaisse ? Clément
Pérot s'est rendu
dans le port des Goudes
pour assister à sa préparation
et bien sûr la déguster. Reportage.
-Les Goudes.
Un petit port marseillais
aux airs de bout du monde.
C'est ici qu'est installé Benjamin
Mathieu, chef cuisinier passionné
par le plat le plus emblématique
de la cité phocéenne.
La bouillabaisse.
-Des petites rascasses,
une vieille, des sars.
-Des sars.
-Ca sort de l'eau, là.
-Ca sort de l'eau.
-Ils sont beaux.
Je vais te prendre les rascasses,
la vieille, quelques sars.
-Allez.
-Ca, ça donne du goût, hein.
-Je sais très bien la faire aussi.
-J'ai jamais goûté.
-J'en ai fait pour 50, 60 personnes,
des belles bouillabaisses.
-Avec Tito, pêcheur aux Goudes
depuis des décennies,
le chef a trouvé
les poissons de roche
indispensables à sa bouillabaisse.
Il va pouvoir les ajouter
au bouillon
qui chauffe déjà
depuis plusieurs heures.
-Du safran.
Quelques épices,
quelques aromates, et après,
voilà, beaucoup de poisson
pour la quantité d'eau qu'on met.
Ca nous assure
d'avoir un très bon goût
de poisson de roche. Le nom
bouillabaisse, c'est du marseillais,
du provençal, c'est simple,
quand ça bout, tu abaisses.
-Issue du bouillon filtré,
la soupe est la 1re étape
de la bouillabaisse,
qui, traditionnellement,
se sert en deux temps.
Dans sa 2e cuisine, Benjamin Mathieu
va s'attaquer à la 2nde partie.
Plusieurs espèces de poissons
sont pochées dans la soupe,
avec des pommes de terre.
-Voilà. Le rouget grondin.
La vive.
Six chapons. C'est à peu près
3, 4 minutes par poisson.
Tout le goût des poissons de roche
va s'infiltrer dans la chair
et pénétrer dans la chair
des poissons
de la bouillabaisse, ça va
leur donner une texture,
une couleur et un goût particulier.
-Une fois le poisson cuit, ne reste
plus qu'à préparer les filets.
Dans le restaurant
du Grand bar des Goudes,
les clients dégustent
leur bouillabaisse face à la mer.
Plat historiquement populaire,
elle est devenue un repas de luxe,
sur commande
à 55 euros par personne.
A cette table,
ces clients belges sont
des inconditionnels.
-Un bouillon de poisson épicé
et avec une certaine structure,
qui est le poisson qui doit être
mixé hyper fin. Donc c'est très bon.
-Que du bon, la mer,
dans mon assiette.
-La Méditerranée dans l'assiette,
les vrais savent, la bouillabaisse
a le goût de Marseille.
-Vous qui avez beaucoup
tourné à Marseille,
ça faisait partie des moments
de pause des tournages,
la bouillabaisse dans le port
de Marseille ou des Goudes ?
De l'Estaque même.
-La bouillabaisse, c'est quand même
assez long et compliqué
à préparer,
c'est pas un plat...
Mais c'est vrai qu'à Marseille,
on connaît
et il y en a un peu dans différents
quartiers ou calanques.
Il y a des pêcheurs, donc le matin,
pouvoir récupérer encore une fois
des produits frais et les préparer
pour faire une bouillabaisse
ou un aïoli, parce que, vraiment,
moi, j'aime beaucoup aussi l'aïoli,
enfin, dans ces spécialités
méditerranéennes,
oui,
oui, les poissons,
la façon dont ça se...
Mais la bouillabaisse,
c'est le safran aussi. Le safran...
-Qui relève le goût.
-Le safran,
c'est quand même une...
-Il faut le doser, le safran.
-C'est vraiment intéressant,
le safran, à travailler.
-Vous en avez dégusté
avec Robert Guédiguian ?
Ca vous arrivait de stopper
le tournage ?
-N'exagérons pas,
si vous dites ça à Robert,
ça va pas du tout.
-Pour célébrer le tournage !
-Non, ça arrive. Oui, c'est arrivé
qu'on aille dans des restaurants,
dans les restaurants marseillais,
dont on connaît, dont on sait,
on connaît les adresses,
on sait où il y a quelques endroits
où la bouillabaisse
est très bonne, oui.
-Vous l'aimez particulièrement ?
Vous êtes assez fan de poisson ?
-Oui, oui, les poissons, mais moi,
j'aime bien les poissons
aussi cuits par exemple
en croûte de sel.
-Ah bon ?
Un peu à l'étouffée.
-Oui, à l'étouffée.
Un poisson frais.
-Grillé, non ?
-Oui, les poissons de toute sorte,
c'est toujours très bon,
mais encore une fois, quand on a
la chance ou même soi-même,
ça m'est arrivé d'être
sur un bateau, de laisser une...
Ca, c'est un peu plus
dans le nord, c'est pas trop
en Méditerranée,
mais de prendre des maquereaux
et de les mettre
directement dans la poêle.
-Ils sont en bancs en plus.
-On en attrape pas mal
et là, ce qu'on mange est
merveilleux. Ca n'a rien à voir
avec le goût qu'on...
même si, parfois,
il y a
des très bons poissonniers,
à Paris, il y a
des très bons poissonniers.
-Il y a eu du transport,
le temps que ça arrive ici.
-Oui, mais il y en a
quand même, on trouve
des poissonneries
où vraiment je sais
que le poisson a été pêché
très tôt le matin,
ils ont voyagé
dans des camions réfrigérés
et ils arrivent,
ils sont quand même assez frais.
-De la mer à la poêle, il y a
pas plus court comme circuit.
-Oui, ça, c'est...
-55 euros,
vous trouvez ça cher
ou ça le mérite,
parce que c'est long à préparer.
-C'est pas mal de travail.
-C'est pas des poissons nobles,
des poissons de roche.
-Oui, justement,
on n'en pêche pas
des grosses quantités.
C'est une pêche très artisanale.
On a son petit pointu le matin,
on part à l'aube.
-C'est pas le chalut.
-Et on ramène quelques poissons.
Ils ont des vies assez difficiles,
ces pêcheurs.
Donc, je pense déjà que le pêcheur
soit rémunéré à son prix normal
et puis, en ce moment, malgré
tout, on n'est pas encore passé
au pointu électrique,
il faut payer
le gasoil, je pense
que tout ça se répercute.
-Sur le prix de la bouillabaisse.
-En effet.
Et du poisson. En 1980,
une charte a été établie
par les restaurateurs marseillais
pour définir la recette officielle
de la bouillabaisse, la vraie,
l'authentique bouillabaisse.
Il y a eu quand même pas mal
de copies. Ca mériterait une AOP,
une AOC, je ne sais pas,
pour consacrer cette recette
authentique de la bouillabaisse ?
-C'est très difficile,
cette notion d'AOP, d'AOC,
parce que, soit ça fige
et donc ça empêche
l'invention et la recherche.
Il y a des vins, le nombre
de vignerons,
on le sait, à l'heure actuelle,
qui sont des vignerons
qui tentent des aventures,
qui tentent des façons
de faire du vin autrement,
et qui ne correspondent pas
aux chartes définies dans la région.
Par exemple.
Et qui donc sont obligés
de sortir de l'appellation.
Il y a marqué "vin de France"
et des fois,
on tombe sur des vins
absolument merveilleux.
Ils ne bénéficient pas
de l'appellation.
-C'est plus difficile à vendre
sans l'appellation.
-Moi, je trouve que...
Après, si on arrive à échapper
de toute façon, de façon générale,
si on arrive à échapper
pour un produit quel qu'il soit
au marketing, si on s'en rend compte
par soi-même, c'est toujours mieux.
Dans un restaurant,
si quelqu'un vous propose
une bouillabaisse pas authentique,
mais vous la trouvez très bonne,
ce sera une bonne.
-Sur les labels,
c'est compliqué de mettre
une AOP ou une AOC sur une recette
qui est faite de plein
de produits différents,
que sur un monoproduit
où on peut donner l'origine, etc.
-Quel est l'intérêt...
-Par contre, qu'une charte
dise quelle est
la recette de l'authentique...
-Après, on peut s'en éloigner.
-Ca bénéficie à qui de faire ça ?
-Je suis sûr que vous avez mangé
une mauvaise bouillabaisse déjà.
-Je ne vais pas dans un restaurant
à touristes à Marseille,
je connais quand même !
-Il y a des touristes anglais
qui se font avoir.
Ils ont pas tourné avec Guédiguian.
-Alors, évidemment,
on parle de Robert Guédiguian,
de Marseille,
dont il est originaire. Son dernier
film, "Et la fête continue",
dans lequel vous jouez,
est bien tourné à Marseille
où, en 2018,
les immeubles de la rue d'Aubagne
se sont effondrés.
Voici la bande-annonce.
-Il faut affirmer sans cesse
que rien n'est fini.
Que tout commence.
Pour gagner, il faut
trois choses.
Un, le programme,
deux, le programme,
et trois, le programme !
-Ce qu'il faudrait, c'est
des nouvelles têtes.
-Surtout de nouveaux cerveaux.
-Je voulais vous présenter Alice,
on va se marier, c'est prévu,
on aura 9 enfants.
-Bienvenue, Alice.
-Courage.
-S'il vous plaît.
-Elle est merveilleuse, non ?
-Vous savez, c'est ma fille.
Merci d'avoir accepté
mon invitation.
-Prenez des rougets.
Ils contiennent
toute la Méditerranée.
-Comme vous.
-Si tu savais...
-Bah quoi ?
-J'ai fait l'amour.
Et tu trouves ça drôle ?
-Ca t'a plu ?
-Bah oui, ça m'a plu.
Avec la situation tragique
des logements, des écoles,
le fruit est mûr !
Il serait atroce de perdre
faute de s'être mis d'accord
sur la tête de liste.
-J'aimerais
qu'une fois, tu sois élue.
-On n'y est pas.
-Alors, Marseille, ça vous plaît ?
Les gens sont de gauche ici.
Ni bourgeois ni racistes,
il y a que des braves gens.
"Emmenez-moi", Charles Aznavour
...
-Pourquoi je suis speed ?
-Quand on veut changer le monde,
on a intérêt
à l'être.
Ils t'attendent tous.
...
Ca se voit.
-Ariane Ascaride joue Rosa,
qui ressemble
à Michèle Rubirola,
qui s'est fait élire à Marseille.
C'est le pitch
qui vous a plu, le scénario,
ou vous dites toujours oui
à Robert Guédiguian ?
-Je lui dis toujours oui.
-Vous n'êtes jamais déçu.
Il se trouve
que je suis jamais déçu,
mais ça rentre pas
en ligne de compte.
Ce qui rentre
en ligne de compte,
c'est la fabrication,
le fait d'être à la tâche
dans notre travail,
qui est de faire du cinéma ensemble.
C'est comme ça
que ça s'est combiné,
que ça s'est agencé.
-C'est une histoire d'amitié ?
-Oui, et donc,
on fabrique du cinéma ensemble,
chacun à son poste,
et chacun avec...
Des fois, ça s'entremêle
un petit peu, mais disons...
Je n'ai pas de raison,
j'ai aucune raison
de refuser.
Je sais qu'on va travailler,
même s'il y a des choses
qui peuvent être, des fois...
Qu'on peut améliorer
sur un scénario,
mais ça va être des broutilles.
Globalement,
l'écriture, ça va,
il commence à savoir le faire.
-Il y a souvent
un message derrière ses films,
de l'authenticité.
C'est ça que vous recherchez ?
C'est engagé, pratiquement,
à sa manière.
-Oui, alors...
C'est engagé,
c'est-à-dire qu'évidemment,
quand on fait du cinéma,
on essaye de...
De projeter, c'est le cas,
c'est le cinéma,
une vision du monde,
de projeter
une morale, une éthique.
On parle beaucoup de morale
et d'éthique en ce moment
pour essayer de se rattraper
aux branches sur des valeurs.
On a des valeurs
pour donner du sens à sa vie,
donner...
C'est de toutes les époques
que les gens
sont concernés par ça.
Quand on écrit,
quand on propose
quelque chose aux autres,
on a forcément la conscience
d'essayer de proposer
quelque chose
qui va les...
Qui va leur apporter quelque chose.
Les gens qui sont dans la salle
sont des clients.
C'est comme au restaurant.
Si vous proposez un produit
que tout le monde connaît,
les gens vont y aller
Si vous voulez un hamburger
avec des frites,
voilà, là, les gens vont y aller,
ils connaissent.
On sait ce que c'est,
on va pas être déçu.
-Avec Robert Guédiguian,
on n'est pas déçu non plus.
-Non, parce que malgré tout,
il y a...
-Il y a un message.
-C'est quelqu'un qui évolue
avec le temps, donc son...
Il traduit sa pensée
du moment, de l'instant,
par rapport
à ce qu'il vit,
à son contexte familial,
par rapport à ce qu'il vit
dans le contexte de...
Social dans lequel il est,
là où il habite, ce qu'il se passe.
Il reçoit des émotions,
il essaye de les traduire
au cinéma et d'en parler.
C'est tout.
Le message ?
Pourquoi il y aurait un message ?
Il y a pas de message.
Il y a 0 message.
Ce serait quoi, le message ?
-C'est une vision de la vie.
-Vraiment,
il y a absolument 0 message.
Il y a simplement montrer la vie
telle que...
Les choses telles qu'on pense
que c'est
et que ça devrait être.
-C'est toujours une vie
assez simple qui est montrée,
authentique.
-C'est-à-dire que, oui...
Pourquoi voulez-vous parler
de gens que vous connaissez pas ?
On parle de nous.
Ca peut arriver,
évidemment, d'écrire
des contes et légendes,
pourquoi pas ?
Mais c'est pas
son propos.
Robert, c'est quelqu'un
qui traduit ce qu'il ressent
et ce qu'il se passe autour de lui.
Il y a pas forcément de message,
il y a 0 message.
Ca serait quoi, le message ?
Ca serait qu'il faut être solidaire,
qu'il faut trouver du lien ?
-J'ai vu un message.
-Allez-y.
-Faire des pâtes,
aux anchois, à l'ail
et aux noix. Moi, je suis
l'estomac de l'émission.
Ca m'a mis l'eau à la bouche
quand j'ai vu le film.
Vous n'êtes pas dans la scène.
Vous les avez goûtées ?
-Oui, je connais la recette
familiale, la recette...
C'est effectivement...
-Ca a l'air d'être une tuerie.
-C'est du côté de la famille
d'Ariane.
-C'est italien,
c'est arménien ?
-Je crois que c'est napolitain,
du côté d'Ariane.
-C'est une bonne promo
pour la recette,
je suis sorti du film
en voulant en faire.
-C'est très bon.
Dans les films de Robert,
il y a quasiment toujours
une recette.
-Il faut faire un livre
de ses recettes !
-Il y a une chanson populaire
et une recette.
On a fait les pâtes aux clovisses,
l'aïoli... Il y a toujours...
Parce que, justement,
parce que le repas,
c'est quelque chose
où les gens se retrouvent,
où il y a du lien populaire.
Donc il n'y a pas de message à...
A parler de ce que les...
De ce que les gens vivent,
tout simplement.
Là, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il y a des immeubles
qui s'écroulent dans une rue
à cause de la précarité
et de quelques-uns qui sont...
Quelques... Qui sont...
Qui cherchent à faire du profit
facilement
avec des gens dans la misère.
On se retrouve dans une situation,
c'est des choses qu'on vit.
C'est arrivé d'autres fois,
c'est arrivé à Marseille,
dans d'autres villes,
Bordeaux il n'y a pas
si longtemps,
dans des tas d'endroits.
Voilà, on part d'une réalité,
il n'y a pas de message.
Il n'y a aucun message à dire :
"Des gens ont vécu des drames
"et on en parle au cinéma."
-De façon subliminale, si,
il y a des vendeurs de sommeil
qui en profitent.
Mais c'est pas "stabilobossé",
c'est juste comme ça.
-Voilà, c'est...
On peut faire...
On peut s'engager.
Evidemment,
quand on montre des exemples...
Si, à l'heure actuelle,
on fait un personnage féminin
qui est...
Qui prend le pouvoir,
quelque part,
qui s'affranchit
du patriarcat,
sans même le savoir,
alors que c'est pas
une militante féministe,
si on écrit ça,
par exemple, voilà,
peut-être que derrière,
il peut y avoir un message.
Evidemment,
on défend certaines valeurs.
Mais défendre des valeurs,
c'est...
-Vous avez l'impression d'être
un artiste
engagé en faisant
ces films ?
-Engagé, franchement,
honnêtement,
j'arrive pas à savoir...
Engagé, ça voudrait dire
que je prends...
Evidemment, j'ai des positions,
je lis des choses,
j'essaye...
-Des valeurs.
-Oui, mais...
J'essaye de les communiquer,
c'est ce que je suis
en train de faire,
quand je parle de...
Etre flexitarien,
c'est un peu ça,
quand je parle de manger
des choses de proximité,
d'à quel point c'est important
de se constituer
des défenses immunitaires
à travers le fait
de vraiment manger les bons...
Les bons oligo-éléments
les bons minéraux,
les bonnes vitamines,
tout ce qui va vous aider
à bien digérer les aliments,
à vous faire une bonne santé
qui va vous permettre de résister
aux épidémies,
aux maladies sociales,
comme on dit maintenant,
que ce soit les...
Les dépressions, les cancers,
ou que ce soit
tous ces phénomènes de société
qui sont essentiellement dus
au stress
que les individus vivent.
Quand je vous dis
que jusqu'à 15 ans,
j'ai vécu tranquillement
sans me préoccuper
de ce que j'allais faire
pour mon avenir, parce qu'à l'époque
on s'en préoccupait pas,
alors que maintenant,
vous interrogez un gamin de 13 ans
ou de 14 ans
dans une cour d'école,
ils sont tous angoissés
parce qu'on leur met la pression.
On leur dit :
"Il faut devenir quelque chose,
"il faut gagner de l'argent."
-Ou angoissé par le monde
ou sa tournure.
-Oui, aussi.
Effectivement,
on prend pas soin de la planète,
on prend pas soin de la façon
dont on mange.
Ils le sentent bien,
les enfants,
qu'on prend pas soin...
On ne se préoccupe
que du rendement économique.
Si on ne se préoccupe
que du rendement économique,
on court
à la catastrophe
au niveau sanitaire,
au niveau éducatif...
On court à la catastrophe.
Donc oui, forcément,
on crée du stress,
on n'a pas le temps...
On parle de ce qui se passe
dans l'assiette,
mais vous vous rendez compte
du nombre de gens
qui mangent des sandwichs
le midi ?
-Encore faut-il pouvoir manger
un sandwich
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
en France,
beaucoup ne mangent pas
à leur faim.
Cette situation s'aggrave.
On en parle et on met
les pieds dans le plat.
L'inflation alimentaire
causée par la guerre
en Ukraine plonge
un nombre important de Français
dans la précarité.
De plus en plus
de personnes vont
aux Restos du Coeur.
Cette année, l'association va être
obligée de refuser du monde.
1,3 million de personnes
seront accueillies.
D'autres bénéficieront des collectes
des banques alimentaires.
Reportage, Hélène Bonduelle,
Clément Pérot.
-Bonjour, c'est une collecte
pour la banque alimentaire.
Merci, madame.
-Trois jours de collecte
dans les grandes surfaces.
-Merci beaucoup, madame.
-Merci, bon courage.
-C'est bien d'avoir donné,
formidable.
-Ici, déjà une quarantaine
de caisses
remplie en une matinée.
-Les gens dehors en ont besoin.
On a ce qu'il faut,
mais eux en ont besoin.
-Une collecte d'autant plus
nécessaire cette année.
Les besoins ont augmenté
de près
de 10 %
au troisième trimestre.
La fédération a dû limiter
ses dons aux associations.
-C'est le choix
cornélien devant nous,
accueillir plus de personnes
et apporter une aide de qualité.
Sur certains produits,
il nous arrive d'être obligé
de restreindre les quantités.
Surtout, on a des stocks
qui sont quasiment à 0
sur certains produits,
et la collecte permet
de remonter les stocks.
C'est vrai
sur les plats cuisinés,
sur les conserves
de fruits ou de légumes.
On demande spécifiquement
les pâtes et le riz,
qui sont de première nécessité
mais qui coûtent cher.
-Inflation,
crise du pouvoir d'achat :
7 millions de personnes dépendent
aujourd'hui de l'aide alimentaire,
comme ici, aux Restos du Coeur
de Grenoble.
-Une banane ?
Je peux vous donner une banane
un peu plus noire gratuite.
-C'est compliqué, c'est pour ça
que j'ai décidé de venir ici.
J'ai reçu l'aide que donnent
les Restos du Coeur.
C'est grâce à eux
que j'ai pu manger.
-Les associations ne sont pas
épargnées
par la crise.
Il y a 3 mois,
les Restos du Coeur
lançaient un appel aux dons.
Il leur manquait
35 millions d'euros.
Les Restos sont obligés
de refuser
des bénéficiaires.
Dans ce centre,
ce sont 60 familles
qui n'ont pas pu être acceptées.
-C'est un crève-coeur
pour les bénévoles
de devoir dire non.
Notre mission, c'est de dire oui
à un maximum de personnes.
-Au niveau national,
près de 10 % des personnes
accueillies
l'an dernier
par les Restos du coeur
ne pourront plus l'être
cette année.
-Les Restos du Coeur obligés
de refuser
du monde, 7 millions
de personnes qui dépendent
de l'aide alimentaire,
ça vous révolte ?
-Ca commence à faire beaucoup.
C'est difficile d'éradiquer
la misère.
La misère n'est pas que produite
par le...
Par l'organisation
de la société,
c'est aussi structurel,
parfois,
à un niveau individuel.
Mais c'est utopique
de supprimer la misère,
mais pas de l'aider
et de...
Et de combler cette injustice
au maximum
que faire se peut.
Qu'il y ait de...
De pouvoir soutenir
les bénévoles,
parce que des gens s'engagent,
donnent de leur temps,
qui travaillent
pour soutenir cette misère.
-C'est normal
que ce soit les banques alimentaires
et pas l'Etat
qui viennent
en aide à ces personnes
qui peuvent pas manger
à leur faim ?
L'Etat donne une petite part
mais est-ce normal...
-Apparemment,
la part de l'Etat n'est pas
suffisante.
-L'Etat doit augmenter
ce qu'il donne aux associations ?
-On dirait.
-C'est une faillite de l'Etat ?
-On dirait que l'Etat ne...
Oui,
l'Etat doit prendre en compte
que la façon dont...
Dont le progrès,
donc la croissance fonctionne
crée ces disparités,
et il ne faut pas laisser
des gens
pour compte.
-Ca peut être conjoncturel,
avec l'inflation qui est née
de la guerre en Ukraine,
mais temporairement, il faut aider ?
Est-ce qu'il faut aider
par des chèques alimentaires ?
Est-ce qu'il faut augmenter
les salaires ?
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Ca, je n'irai pas
sur ce terrain-là,
d'avoir des solutions
vraiment précises
au niveau économique.
Je vais aller voir
notre ministre
pour lui dire...
Sinon, ça va pas marcher.
Je pense
effectivement, je crois,
qu'il y a...
Qu'il faut développer
un sentiment
de solidarité.
Ne serait-ce que si les gens
qui sont
dans cette précarité
sentaient
qu'ils sont pris en compte,
que l'Etat
donne... Dit des mots,
des mots qui ne paraissent pas
forcément vains,
des mots qui sont...
Des mots, oui,
de compréhension.
L'envie de...
De faire des propositions,
l'envie de faire des propositions,
des consultations,
de rencontrer...
De rencontrer ces bénévoles,
de rencontrer
les gens, de se demander
ce qu'on peut améliorer.
"Qu'est-ce qu'on peut améliorer
pour le sort de ces gens-là ?"
-Aujourd'hui,
ce dialogue n'existe plus ?
On est trop individualistes ?
-Oui, de façon générale,
on a...
Il ne faut pas
que l'Etat soit considéré
comme seul...
Il y a déjà la sécurité sociale,
il y a déjà beaucoup de choses
que...
Dans lesquelles l'Etat vient
intervenir
dans la solidarité
pour aider les gens
qui sont malades,
qui ne peuvent pas travailler.
Il y a des tas de...
-Des aides...
-Il y a déjà...
L'Etat est déjà pas mal.
Je pense aussi que...
On est dans une démocratie,
on est ici à l'Assemblée nationale.
Ca veut dire qu'il faut que les gens
se sentent responsables.
Une démocratie, ce n'est pas
uniquement aller voter
pour n'importe quoi
et pour n'importe qui.
Donc il faut...
Il faut simplement
se sentir responsable.
Donc oui,
avoir...
Organiser des choses
à un niveau d'Etat
pour que des gens
qui se sentent responsables
puissent être considérés,
écoutés
dans leurs solutions.
Ca a été fait
sur des problèmes dits...
Comme sur l'écologie et tout ça,
on fait des réunions,
on discute.
On fait des conventions.
Eh bien oui, pour résoudre
ces problèmes-là,
de précarité, de pauvreté,
je suis sûr que si on faisait
des conventions...
-Ca pourrait fonctionner ?
-On aurait des solutions.
-Vous êtes, sans trahir,
plutôt un homme de gauche.
Est-ce que vous trouvez
que la gauche est présente,
qu'elle est bien représentée ?
-La gauche...
La gauche, c'est compliqué
parce que...
La gauche, elle a...
Elle s'est trahie elle-même
pendant...
Ces derniers temps,
parce qu'elle a fait le jeu
de ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
la prédominance de la croissance
et la prédominance
de la recherche du bonheur
à travers l'économie,
à travers la...
A travers le développement...
La gauche a contribué au fait
qu'on fasse pousser de l'argent
sur des terrains où il était pas
normal de le faire.
On a mis
des engrais,
on a mis des pesticides,
là, pour faire pousser
de l'argent.
Et on en a fait pousser pas mal.
Et donc,
les gens qui étaient
historiquement
dans une sensibilité de gauche
se sont quand même sentis trahis
de ça.
-C'est votre cas ?
-Oui, c'est mon cas.
-On va passer au dessert,
c'est le péché mignon.
-Oui, avec une gourmandise
qui a le vent en poupe,
une pavlova,
du nom d'une danseuse russe,
Anna Pavlova. Il s'agit
d'un dessert constitué
d'une meringue italienne,
surmontée de crème fouettée
et de fruits rouges.
Là, aujourd'hui,
c'est de la mangue.
La petite histoire, à vérifier,
dit que ce dessert aurait
été créé
lors d'une tournée
de Pavlova en Océanie.
L'Australie et la Nouvelle-Zélande
se revendiquent la paternité
de ce dessert,
qui plaît à notre invité.
Vous l'avez découvert où ?
En Australie ?
En Nouvelle-Zélande ?
-Ni l'un ni l'autre,
je ne suis jamais allé aussi loin.
-A Marseille !
-Alors, je vais certainement
contredire
l'origine de la pavlova.
C'est aussi une petite madeleine
pour moi.
C'était un dessert
qui était mon préféré,
gamin.
Mais à l'époque,
on appelait ça la polonaise.
On appelait ça la polonaise
et ça s'appelait pas
la pavlova.
Et puis la polonaise a disparu.
J'en trouvais plus
dans les pâtisseries.
J'en trouvais plus.
Et puis, il y a quelques années,
est revenue la pavlova.
Rires
-Et c'est à votre goût.
-Et c'est...
C'est exactement la même chose
que la polonaise
que je mangeais
quand j'étais gamin.
-Qui s'appelle
la pavlova. On finit toujours
cette émission en musique,
avec la vôtre,
et puis vous nous dites
pourquoi.
"La nuit je mens",
Alain Bashung
...
C'est Alain Bashung.
Pourquoi cette chanson ?
-J'aurais pu en choisir plusieurs
d'Alain Bashung,
j'aurais pu en choisir
tellement d'autres.
Voilà, c'est...
J'ai regretté de ne l'avoir
jamais vu sur scène.
Il a représenté quelque chose
dans ma génération.
Depuis son premier tube,
même si j'étais
déjà âgé, son premier tube,
"Gaby".
Voilà, il y avait un décalage,
une forme de poésie qui me...
Qui me touchait beaucoup,
et puis sa musique aussi,
et puis, voilà...
Il a fait...
Il a fait des chansons
merveilleuses,
donc j'avais envie d'écouter.
-Merci de nous la faire partager.
Merci, Jean-Pierre Darroussin,
d'avoir accepté
notre invitation.
Merci à Chez Françoise
pour cette blanquette
et cette pavlova délicieuses.
On se retrouve
la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...